he's Albert Breyer NBC Sports Boston and
of course the mmq b.com he's got a mock
draft out I'm not gonna mock the mock
draft I want to know about the process
of the mock draft and that's why we've
invited Albert to join us now
Albert thanks for joining us give us
your top five right now I have gonna
first the brown Josh I was going second
to the Giants Bradley child's the
defensive and fermentative state going
third to the Colts think l'm Berkeley
the running back from the from Penn
State going forth and the Browns and
then Josh Rogers going to the Broncos
not really Dan they're moving parts here
we haven't gone through free agency what
trays there might be and so you know
there's a long way to go between now and
April but I can tell you the public
easiest things up and so I I made a
bunch of phone calls last week I came up
with a list for analyst by about by
about eight teams better day it
rearranged a few times and that was the
final product how do you know somebody's
telling you the truth you know I've been
doing this long enough where I have a
good idea of who I can trust and you
know the draft funny you know a lot of
times word gets out around you know the
scouting community and through the
coaching community and one thing I've
learned about doing this and this will
continue over the next two months is
that a lot of times you can learn a lot
about what other teams are doing from
coaches now they might not tell you the
coaches and Scouts might not tell you
what they're planning on doing but
they'll have information on what other
teams are doing and so that's sort of
how you go through that process the
other thing that's been helpful for me
this year is that you know Peter had me
do a draft column every week in the fall
and I found because there's less
pressure on the college scouts guys are
out on the road at that time of year to
conceal information there's less
pressure on them to
treat everything as proprietary that you
know you'll get really good information
in the fall and so a lot of the
conversations I had then and I've always
had those sorts of conversations and a
fall that I had more of them this year
you wind up learning a lot about the
players both are strengths or weaknesses
who has off-field issues all that sort
of stuff so sort of just a process you
go through where you know you learn how
to trust you also learn how to get
reliable information it feels like say
Kwan Barclay is the best player in this
draft or at least the guy who is skilled
position and this is what I've been told
by two people two Scouts who said he's
the best player but because we're not
sure how to evaluate or define what the
running back is worth now that's where
it's sort of a fluid market here on on
running backs if this was in a previous
generation say Kwan Barclay is going
number one or would it still be a
quarterback going number one if this was
a different NFL you know I see the top
two prospects in the draft after a
running back in the guard single and
bartlein and Quentin Nelson from Notre
Dame and so this is a different type of
year and that you know those are two
positions that generally aren't valued
very highly by NFL teams but we've seen
a little bit of a rebirth running back
position and I think a new prototype
submerged and and what that is is the
230 pound guy who can play on all three
downs who can catch the ball I can pass
block we can do everything and that's
what Todd Gurley was that's what Ezekiel
Elliott was wondering for that's a
little bit more of a throwback but
certainly that's what's a quantum
Berkeley is a guy who can be absolutely
everything and if you want to compare
the guys the last years a lot of the
scouts that I taught to think he's
better than Zeke better than Leonard
fournette better than Todd Gurley
and so I hope if there are very many
questions about him as a prospect the
biggest question so it seems passing up
there is really comfortable spending
that high pick on a player at that
position and you know what a lot of that
comes down to Dan is that there are
teams of feel like we can get running
back in a third or fourth round and
think I might not be safe on Berkeley
but we'll gamble that we can
somebody pretty good there's less of a
chance that you're going to find a left
tackle or a pass rusher or a corner that
late in the draft so you know we should
address those needs earlier on and then
just find a way to make it work at
running back later and you can look at
last year's fast there's a good example
of that like one or that great pick for
the Jaguars I don't think anybody would
argue they did well with the fourth
overall picks but then you look down in
the third round and you see the NFL's
rushing champion Kareem hunt is sitting
there you know so you can solve that you
can solve you know the question of who's
going to be running back later on to the
draft where at other positions is all
the more difficult to do it he's Albert
Breer the mmq b.com with his mock draft
you can tweet him at at Albert Breer BR
e er what are the team's think of Baker
Mayfield I think one of the things that
you're gonna have to come to a comfort
level with what height is an issue and
you might have to run your offense a
little bit differently than you
traditionally would and so there are
those sorts of things I think the bigger
question is going to be how comfortable
you are with him from a personality
standpoint and one thing that I you know
I've been told by a couple teams that
they noticed during Senior Bowl week in
Mobile was you know a lot of kids are
going to this process and treat it like
a job interview and they'll put in a put
on their best face and Baker didn't
really do that you know from what I
understand he carried himself in mobile
very much the way he carried himself in
Norman Oklahoma the last two years sort
of this attitude for better or worse
this is who I am
hmm and some teams love that you know
and he's a very popular player in the
Oklahoma program the coaches love them
teammates love them all of that but that
personality isn't for everybody
and so I think that's one of the big
things we're going to be talking about
over the next couple of weeks not to be
the bad guy but he's got a certain
swagger to him and he's got this
personality about him and I think for a
lot of teams that are looking for
quarterbacks with the upper reaches the
trap the questions going to be how does
this guy sitting on my coaching staff
how is this guy fit in with our locker
room
he's already showing signs right now
that you know this is who he is and
that's not going to change and so you
really are if you're gonna buy into him
you're buying into the guy that he was
the last year's at Oklahoma
why is it Lamar Jackson's completion
percentage at Louisville is singled out
and maybe you should play another
position but Josh Allen's completion
percentage at Wyoming which was lower
than Lamar Jackson's is not singled out
the difference with Josh Allen has
helped there he is
you know and 3605 is 240 pounds and that
he's got arm town that's off the charts
and and you know here's the thing I
think the way you have to look at it is
with Josh Allen if you take 60 plays in
in a game I think Scouts will find 20
plays where they'll say to themselves
okay well this looks like a franchise
quarterback this looks like a guy can
stick right into my offense and you know
then you've got to become comfortable
with the fact that the other 40 plays it
might have been a little bit of a bass
and all right like so can you be more
consistent whereas I think with Lamar
Jackson because he's a different type of
player you almost have to be comfortable
with a completely different type of game
you know that's the way those Scouts are
looking at this they're not looking in
completion percentage so much as they
are looking at what these guys look like
in a play to play basis and so you know
Josh Allen it's more how do you think
that he's going to be able to turn you
know a handful of things that look
really good into the way he plays all
the time
first is Lamar Jackson it's are you
wanting to sort of adjust some of the
things you do authentically to fit him
and if you do those things is he gonna
be able to hold up physically cuz he's
not as physically big as Josh Talon he's
built a little bit and I don't think
Heights the problem I've heard that I
think it's more his frame and how much
weight he'll be able to put on and
whether or not if he does play that way
in the NFL and you are you know using
him as a runner whether or not is
physically going to be able to hold up
because we've seen that questions with
some was some guys that have played that
way there are guys like Russell Wilson
who built like running backs and who
know how to protect themselves and are
able to survive
using their legs as weapons in the NFL
and then you've got other guys like
Robert Griffin the third who you know
played that way as a rookie but it
wasn't sustainable and so that's one of
the questions with him is you have to
look at his frame and whether or not if
he is going to play the way that he
played in college in the NFL whether or
not he's going to be able to hold up
physically Thank You Albert we'll be
keeping an eye out for the next mock
draft on the mmq be calm for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]